[MUSIC PLAYING]
My father who art in heaven--
my dad got hurt by the police.
Please tell him to
get a better job.
In Jesus name, we say amen.
Amen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Kenya has been ranked
dismally as one
of the most corrupt
countries in the world.
MP!
MP!.
MP.
We have a right-- we
have a right to protest.
Boniface Mwangi.
Folks, this young man
is, one word, fearless.
Why are you arresting me?
Why are-- what have I done?
What have I done?
Where are you going?
I'm going to topple
the government.
Whoa.
I can only imagine
how scared I'd be,
seeing my husband
taking to the streets.
Now he wants to try
his hand at politics.
What?
My heart is made up
that I'm going to vie.
Ha, ha, hah Whoa.
This is how you're
telling it to me.
I mean.
He's a good man. We need to vote for him.
Does Boniface Mwangi
have deep pockets?
No, he doesn't is
he on the right side
of the tribal kingpin?
No, he's not.
He's going to be a casualty
of other forces beyond him.
Do not come home.
They will kill you.
Activist Boniface Mwangi
receiving death threats
that, for the first time, target
his wife and children as well.
It feels like just jumping
into a river of crocodiles.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everyone.
My name is Roger Ross Williams.
And welcome to the Academy
Visiting Artist Series.
I'm a documentary
filmmaker based in New York
and Amsterdam, the Netherlands.
And I've been
making documentaries
to show real life
and real situations
and real people for a long time.
A number of my films
are focused in Africa.
And I'm passionate about
helping the next generation
of African filmmakers
tell their own stories.
I am so excited to be
here in conversation
with the amazing African
filmmaker and dear
friend of mine, Toni Kamau.
Toni is an IDA, PDA
nominee and the youngest
female African
documentary producer
to be invited as a member
of the Academy of Motion
Pictures, Arts, and
Sciences, documentary branch.
As a producer and
writer and founder of We
Are Not the Machine, a
Nairobi-based production
company, she tells stories
of outsiders, rebels,
and changemakers.
The Sundance Special Jury prize
winner and POV co-production
Softie produced by Toni and
directed by Sam Soko premiered
at the Sundance in 20--
Sundace Festival in 2020 in
the world cinema documentary
feature competition.
It was selected as the
opening night film of Hot Docs
and won the Oscar-qualifying
best African documentary award
at the Durban Film Festival.
Toni is currently in production
on a feature documentary
on home and belonging
and in development
on a documentary series
exploring the legacy
of colonialism in Kenya.
I am so excited to get a
chance to talk to Toni.
And Toni, thank
you for being here.
Well, thank you so much for
the introduction, Roger.
It's--
Yes.
Good evening, talking
to you- it feels
like this is coming full
circle because you are actually
the first documentary
director I ever saw
at IDFA who looked like me.
It was God Loves Uganda.
And I keep on telling
everyone the story.
Pete, a Kenyan
director, and I, we
saw you for the first time
talking about your experience.
And I think at that
moment, we realized
that we, as people
of color, could tell
stories for the global stage.
So it's just amazing to be
here and talking to you.
Well, I was really excited when
I met you for the first time.
Because for so long, so
many people have been--
from the outside, have
been going to Africa
and telling your stories.
And it was so exciting to meet
the community of filmmakers who
are telling your own stories.
It's about time.
I think I'm going to start
with the beginning for you
and your career and sort of,
what inspired you to pursue
a film and a career in
filmmaking and documentary
filmmaking.
Yeah.
I mean, I've always loved story.
When I was a child,
my mother was away.
My late mother was away
for most of my childhood.
She was studying
in the UK, her PhD.
And the only way I was really
able to understand the world
that she lived in, which just
seemed so separate and alien,
was by watching TV.
So I think for me, TV
holds a special place
because it gives you a chance
to explore other worlds
and other cultures.
And yeah.
I think I went to
film school in Kenya.
I was initially interested
in working in fiction.
But I watched Hoop
Dreams, absolutely
loved the documentary.
And it was just so interesting
to understand that, oh,
my God, you can get this insight
into people's experiences.
And you can find this
sense of universality
that I felt was kind of
missing from fiction in a way
that I can't really
articulate right now.
But it just felt like it was
something so special to me.
Yeah.
You know, I think it's
important for our audience
to understand the difference
between documentary and fiction
storytelling.
And the beautiful thing about
documentary and something
like Hoop Dreams is
that you can live,
you can follow a real-life
story for, sometimes,
people, 10 years or
longer, or 20 years,
and really get the full
scope of the human existence.
And that's a beautiful thing.
So tell me, you know, what kind
of stories do you like to tell?
What is the sort of, you
know, what does Tony love?
What are-- you're
like, you know,
you tend to really focus
on stories of people
like Softie, like
challenging the system.
But there's also a deep
humanity to the types of stories
that you tell.
But tell us what you
love, what kind of stories
you really love.
Yeah.
So really drawn to working
with talented directors
like Sam Soko of Softie
and Pete of I am Samuel.
And you know, we
come from a society--
I'll speak specifically
about Kenya
because that's where I grew up.
We come from a country where
from the time you go to school,
actually, kindergarten,
you're told to conform.
You're told to toe the line.
You're never allowed
to question authority.
Everything is supposed
to be cookie cutter.
And it's because
our education is
based on colonial ways of
framing the world and training
people to be these factory
workers or people work on farms
for the colonial masters.
So people like Boniface,
our subjects in Softie,
are very interesting to me
because I always wonder,
what is it about
them that makes them
rail against the system,
that makes them actually
question their place in society,
or how society's working.
So I find those kind of
people very, very fascinating,
specifically because of
the community I grew up in.
And I want to be a little
bit more like them.
So I'm really attracted to those
kind of stories, to be honest.
Because I'm just
constantly trying
to unravel and unpack that with
every single project that I get
attached to.
Yeah.
Yeah, And taking on
a project like Softie
was really interesting because
you had all of this footage.
And talk about
like, as a producer,
as a filmmaker, how you
found that unique story
within the footage.
Wow.
Yes.
That was, outside
of fundraising,
that was one of the
biggest, I think,
challenges that
we had in Softie.
Because Soko, the director,
and the team, I mean,
we'd filmed over 500 hours.
We had over 500
hours of footage.
And it was very easy to, maybe,
try and tell this narrative
about a country that's
struggling with democracy
and this activist who's
always on the streets.
But Soko, as a director
and us as a film team,
we're very committed
to telling the family
story, the personal story.
Because we felt that was
also important to look
at this young marriage,
two people struggling
to balance priorities.
Because we felt
there was a parallel
between that and citizens
of a country balancing
their relationship, or trying
to navigate their relationship,
with a young state.
So I think for us, we really
had a lot of conversations
as a film team, just
about like, what's
the core of the story, what do
we want audiences to leave here
with.
And when we felt that we
had an understanding of what
our arc would be,
it was, I think,
easier for Soko
and the edit team
to really be able to now
dive back into the footage
and start marking footage.
And once everyone
like, I think there's
a bit of a stalemate where
people were talking about which
scenes should be in the film,
one of our amazing editors,
Ryan Mullins, just came and
just quickly edited together
a rough structure.
And then we had
a framework to be
able to kind of build around.
So I would say the
beginning was fast and very
slow at the same time.
Because it took us--
it took us about a year
to get to a structure
from when we actually
committed to editing.
| it also happened very
fast because the edits
on the computer was done in
like, a few weeks after months
of talking and months of
looking through footage.
Yeah.
Well, yeah.
I mean these films are built
in the edit room, for sure.
So talk to me about the role of
a producer in documentary film,
sort of, how that role
progresses and changes
from development to production
to post-production to selling
and marketing the film.
Yeah.
I think being a producer,
it's always one of, I think,
the hardest roles to explain.
I think, especially,
specifically in documentary
because it's become so nebulous.
Sometimes, people
think a producer
is someone who brings money
to the table or someone who
brings access.
So it is something that the
industry is grappling with,
just in terms of
who should actually
get credited as a producer.
But I would-- how
I see producing,
I would say that you're the one
who ensures that the director's
creative vision is protected.
And you're the one who
ensures that you're
able to gather
resources, whether it's
a team, whether it's
fundraising, you know,
whether it's the
right publicist when
you get to releasing the film.
So you make sure you gather
the resources that are also
able to ensure that the
director's creative vision is
achieved.
And you're also a
therapist sometimes.
Because--
That's so true.
--you know, directing
documentaries is not easy.
So I think that's why it's
also important to just
have a good relationship
with the director
because you talk a lot about
just the process of making
the film or the process
of dealing with characters
and subjects.
Because it's-- I mean, it's
a complicated relationship,
the relationship between a
director and the subject.
You are-- you're friends
to a certain degree
but on the other hand, you
have to separate yourself
from the person so you can
maintain a level of objectivity
when you're trying to figure
out what the story is.
So it's a delicate balance.
And I think having
a producer involved,
especially from the beginning,
is really important,
I would say, for directors,
for documentary directors,
to just have that creative
sounding-- creative sounding
board.
But if I was to just talk about
it in a very structured manner,
I would say the producer
is, in documentary,
you make sure that you're able
to get access to characters
in writing, releases, so
making sure you secure releases
in the beginning of
development, or at least,
at some point in production,
so that you can actually
be able to finish the
film and release it.
Then I would say it's
also about helping
to put the proposal together
with the director and the pitch
package, reviewing
materials, fundraising.
For example, Softie,
after we fundraised we
were a global team
that was spread
in Kenya, Canada, the UK.
So a lot of my job, when we were
getting into post-production,
was just coordinating
the team and managing
different interests.
We all believed in the film.
But we always had
to just like, keep
on checking in and making sure
that we were on the same page
and that we were--
every time the edit
changed, we just
had to make sure that we
were on the same path.
And we also had to make
sure that we were all
being supportive of the director
because it's very easy to lose
track and for
people to be making
different films within
the same project,
as I have come to learn.
Yeah.
And I think outside of
that, coordinating the team.
It's also just about
meeting deadlines
whether it's submitting for
grants, whether it's submitting
the film to festivals.
And once the
documentary is complete,
and you've secured all releases
for music and any archive
and that you made
sure that you've
produced the project
within budget,
you know, the next
stage is then managing
the release of the film, which
was something very new for me
with my first two features,
Softie and I am Samuel.
Because my previous experience
was working as a documentary
director and producer for
Al Jazeera, BBC World.
And when you finished the
documentary, that was it.
You didn't have to think
about anything else.
You locked picture,
you delivered.
And that was it.
So I would say one of the
steepest learning curves,
specifically for Softie, for
Soko and I, because we were
both producers in that,
was managing the release
and distribution and
dealing with sales agents.
That was quite hectic.
And then an awards
campaign because we
got nominated to the PGA.
That was quite-- that was
a steep learning curve.
A whole new set of skill
sets were developed.
It's a lot.
And you know,
people often ask me.
They're like, what
does a producer do?
I'm like, they do a lot.
They do everything.
They're running the show.
They're keeping it all
together for all of us.
Let's break it down a
little bit for people
who want to get into
this, into filmmaking.
So the most important thing
is how do people fund?
You know, how do people
fund these projects?
How do you find funding?
How did you go about that
with Softie and I am Samuel?
Yeah.
So I mean, it's interesting.
In Kenya, there are
not that many sources
of public financing or public
funding for factual documentary
projects.
A lot of times, when we're
working on this social justice
documentaries, we're doing
the exact kind of work
that government
public funds do not
want to be released
out into the world.
So I mean, how we got our
funding was first to DocuBox,
which you're on the board of.
I am on the board.
Which was started by fellow
Academy member, Judy Kibenge,
co-founded, yeah,
founded by Judy Kibenge.
So we got some funding from her.
And with Softie,
we also got funding
from the Ford Foundation.
Actually, Soko got seed funding,
before I joined the project,
from Ford Foundation.
Because in the
beginning, he wanted
to do an activistic--
activist manual.
He had no intentions of
actually doing a feature.
Like, yeah, he keeps
on saying that.
And I'm like, 500 hours
for an activist manual,
not very efficient.
No.
Yeah.
But it was amazing
because he keeps
on the telling that story.
And I just think it's the most
amazing story in the world
because it's such
a fantastic film.
Yeah.
So yeah.
So he got seed funding from
Ford Foundation around 2013
and Doc Society and
Hot Docs came on board.
I joined the
project after he had
done about four years,
done the majority
of principal photography.
And then we got
into Hot Docs forum.
And we were the
first Kenyan team
to pitch at Hot Docs forum,
which we had no idea what
we were going to do there.
But we went there anyway.
And at first, we
were really nervous
because we had seen
the IDFA forums, which
seemed very intimidating.
And the Hot Docs forums where
people like, oh, my god.
It was--
Yeah.
There were 500 people.
We were so nervous.
And we were thinking, should--
so do we have to have a script,
and do we have to be very formal
like a lot of these filmmakers
from Europe who have
all of these credits.
And I mean, it was
amazing because we
were working with an incredible
team at EyeSteel Film.
And the team there,
Miller and Bob,
had done some
incredible pictures.
I remember there's a
pitch they did in Hot Docs
where the were wearing fireman's
suits and with the audience.
Then they just stood up and
everyone was like, what?
I can't remember what -
Everyone talks about that pitch.
But I don't think--
I don't know if anyone
remembers what the film was.
Yeah but they were so
amazing at pitches.
And I mean, we really discussed
what made a great pitch.
And outside of the basics
of being able to say who,
what, where, and to be able
to access to the character
and what the team was,
what made a great pitch
was leaning into your
authentic selves as a team
and why you, as a team,
wanted to do this project.
And for us, Softie, was
a story and a project
that we were working
on because we had
a deep love for our country.
We had a lot of questions about
our complicated relationship
with it.
And that's what we leaned into.
And as a first time producer
pitching at Hot Docs,
I didn't have a list of credits.
So actually, when we were
pitching at Hot Docs, we just--
we leaned into authentic selves.
And we gave ourselves roles.
Like, I'm very enthusiastic.
And we were happy to be there
as a first time filmmaker so we
just--
we riled up the crowd.
And we're like, yeah, happy
to be here, like, shout out
to Doc Society, shout
out to Just Film,
shout out to all our partners,
and we love our country,
we love being here.
And I think everyone
was a bit shocked.
They were like, oh,
my god the Africans
are very like, expressive.
You [INAUDIBLE]
Everyone was like, so happy.
And I think we came
with great energy
because we really did not want
to be telling another story
about how Africa--
an African country has
a failed democracy.
That was not the story
that we wanted to tell.
We wanted to tell a story of
hope, a story of possibility.
And we leaned into
that with our pitch.
And Soko did a pitch where he
was talking over the trailer.
So he was weaving in and out
of the trailer, which is risky.
And it worked.
And out of participating
in Hot Docs forum, which
was very scary for us,
yeah, we got POV on board
as a co-producing partner,
co-production partner.
We got BBC Storyville later
down the line, Sundance.
So I would say, Softie--
You got it all.
Yeah.
I mean, not--
You got the momentum.
But it took six months,
six months to a year,
of talking back and
forth with people
who had expressed an interest.
Because fundraising is about--
it's also about-- it's
about establishing
a relationship with someone.
It's about getting someone to
be part of the team as a funder.
We have been
fortunate that we had
people doubling down their
commitment more than once.
Doc Society doubled down
their commitment three times.
And even supported impact.
Luminate, our other funder,
doubled down their commitment.
And that's because we didn't
treat them as an ATM machine.
But we treated them as
partners, as collaborators.
And we kept on having
conversations with them
about what our vision
was for the documentary
and for our audience
outreach and engagement.
Yeah.
I mean, you know,
let's talk a little bit
about of breaking into the doc.
Kenya, and what you guys have
done as in this nonfiction
space in Kenya is remarkable.
It's a game changer for
non-fiction in Africa.
And what was-- when
I first met you guys,
and I believe it was--
I can't remember if it
was Hot Docs or IDFA,
it was that enthusiasm.
I remember like, you and Judy
Kibinge from the production,
just coming up to me so excited.
And like, we are so excited.
We want to meet people.
And I was like,
you guys are great.
And I was like, you
want to meet people.
And I pointed out--
I remember we were in I think
it was Sheffield, the Sheffield
Doc Fest.
And I was pointing out
people in the room.
And then you guys
would go up to them.
And I like, that
person's important.
That's Simon Kilmurry.
He's head of the IDA.
And you guys would go, OK,
I'm going to go up to him.
Like, hey, Simon.
And it's just so great.
And what you've
done is you gained
the respect of the industry.
And you've charted
a way for, really,
for African nonfiction
filmmakers to--
people to take notice and
be like, wait a minute.
Why are we going
there and telling
these devastating
stories instead
of embracing the stories
that we want to tell.
But how is it navigating
the Kenyan film industry
versus the Western
film industry?
You know, because there's been
some issues around censorship,
around all kinds of
problems in Kenya
of getting your films released.
Yeah.
I mean, I could just speak a
little bit to our enthusiasm
for being out there at
IDFA, Sheffield, Hot Docs.
Listen.
We, for a very long
time, people who
look like me, people who
look like Soko, Pete,
we're not telling our stories.
And the reason why I
said earlier on like, I
feel like it's coming full
circle, and I truly do mean it,
is because for a
long time, we thought
that creative documentaries
or documentaries that
could be at A festivals,
or even fiction films that
could be at A
festivals, that was
the preserve of Western
filmmakers, largely
white, male Western filmmakers.
And it just felt
like something that
was completely inaccessible for
us in so many different ways
because we don't have
access to development
funding for projects.
For a long time,
we really did not
have the skill set to really
be able to do, to produce,
and direct creative
documentaries,
and creative character-driven
documentaries.
Soko, honestly, just kept
on filming and filming.
And he had such an
incredible access.
incredible subjects
that he was filming with.
And it was through
watching documentaries.
It was through watching
these lectures, videos,
we were watching about
Hot Docs and IDFA
online, where we were mostly
seeing these white filmmakers
talking about the process.
So when we got there, we
were ready to take advantage
of every single opportunity.
Because we also
understood that this
wasn't just about us
as a film team, but it
was also just about
the next generation.
I don't even see
It was about the
next filmmakers who
are going to come up
after us and those people
who have projects
in post-production
like Zippy Kimundu.
She is doing an amazing
documentary about Mau Mau.
So we were going to
kick the door open
and leave it open so that
other people can come there.
Because we don't want to
be the only people having
a seat at the table.
And we did not want to be
seen as these unicorns,
these special Africans, who
can tell specific films.
Because we wanted
people to understand
there was more of
us coming there.
So that's why we were
very enthusiastic.
Because we knew that this
is an amazing opportunity
that could potentially transform
our independent documentary
industry in Kenya.
So that's why there's
all this enthusiasm
with that project and all the
other projects that we do.
Because we do truly
feel like we're
in a very special moment, where
we are finally having access,
and we're finally talking to the
right people at the, probably,
right room, maybe not the right
table but probably, right room.
But that's OK because
before, we didn't even
know the room existed.
And I would say navigating
the Kenyan industry
when it comes to censorship,
I would see a lot of that.
I mean, it's difficult
right now in Kenya
because Softie got an 18
classification with the Kenyan
Film and Censorship Board.
They said-- yeah, it did.
It did.
What is this 18 classification?
What does that mean?
18 plus.
So only people over the age
of 18 could watch in theater--
Why is that?
--or TV in its current format.
And the reasons given
was police brutality,
which I thought was amazing.
And you know, they talked
about post-election violence.
A lot of the stuff
had been on TV.
They couldn't outright ban it
because we've been so public
about our release at Sundance.
And we kept making
noise about it.
Because that was our strategy.
Let's make as much noise
as possible about the film.
Let's be enthusiastic.
Let's get everyone talking
so that-- let's just
make it so difficult for anyone
to even try and ban this film.
Because we wanted it to be seen.
And that was just our strategy.
Let's be loud.
Let's be noisy.
Let's celebrate
as much as we can
because who wants to
be a party pooper.
So I think that was our--
that was our strategy with
dealing with censorship.
And distribution is
another challenge in Kenya.
We really had to--
I mean, we really, really had
to lobby the local distributor,
Crimson, to be able to even
just look at the documentary.
Because in Kenya, when people
think about documentaries,
they think that it's
about water, building
a well, or something like that.
Right.
They forgot to think
that it's engaging.
We had to keep on calling the
distributor and telling her,
hey, have you watched it?
Hey, have you watched it?
So she just finally watched
it after she got tired
of me calling her.
And when she watched, it,
she's like, oh, my god.
This is amazing.
We need to get in
all the theaters.
And I think that--
so I think for us,
because we're in the phase where
we're kind of pioneers in Kenya
when it comes to
independent documentaries,
theatrical documentaries--
because people have
done other sorts
of documentaries and fiction--
there's a lot of
education that we
need to do in our generation.
And we're happy to do
it because we absolutely
love documentary storytelling.
I've found it very
transformative in my life.
Yeah.
So you're educating people
all around, both sides.
You're educating the Kenyans.
Yeah.
Incredible.
And you mentioned a
lot of organizations.
And I think that it's
important for filmmakers
to understand some
of the opportunities
in these organizations.
I believe I met you--
I think I met you,
it was Blue Ice.
Yes.
It was Blue Ice
where you and Pete
were working on I am Samuel.
And I remember I
saw that work, and I
saw both of your enthusiasm.
And I was like, I'm signing on.
I want to be executive producer
I want to work with these guys.
So talk about some
of the opportunities
available to filmmakers in Kenya
like Blue Ice, and of course,
the amazing DocuBox.
Yes.
I think right now is
an incredible time
to be an independent
storyteller from continent.
Because I think
right now there's
an increased interest
in diverse stories.
A lot of people committed
to that across the board.
So I'm just like,
if you have an idea,
and you want to get it done,
I think now's the time.
Don't wait.
So I would say, organizations
that you could reach out to
for production funding
would be DocuBox
which is based in Kenya.
It's East Africa's first
independent documentary film
fund.
Then there's also DocA
which is Africa-wide.
They have development funding.
They also have
production funding
I know they have impact
distribution funding.
Outside of that,
they have their funds
outside of the continent
like Hot Doc's Blue Ice
that's interested in supporting
African storytellers.
Both my projects Softie and I am
Samuel got funding from there.
And I know so many other
filmmakers who got that.
There's IDFA as
well and Sundance.
Sundance has also just
refocused its fund
to finance documentary
storytellers
from the communities where
they're telling the stories.
So that means, no more--
they're interested
in really supporting
parachute filmmaking,
as I like to call it.
Exactly.
Comes in and tells
the story and leaves.
I mean, they want
someone who actually
has some level of
connection and understanding
of their communities, which
is why I'm just saying,
right now is a perfect time
to be developing stories.
Yeah.
I'd say grants, Ford Foundation.
I would say-- I would say,
as an African storyteller
at this point,
it's mostly grants.
It's mostly grant organizations,
so specific documentary grant
organizations like the one
I talked about and also
thematic funding organizations.
Because they could
be an organization
that doesn't directly
support documentary.
But maybe it's a climate
change organization.
And you could be
able to convince
them to finance your documentary
or to support it and later
on support its distribution and
in their target communities.
That's, I think, one of the
interesting ways you could
be able to raise financing.
And what's really
interesting, what's changing,
now is there are now
commercial opportunities.
And now huge streamers like
Netflix are on the continent
and looking for content.
And that gives an
opportunity for filmmakers
to actually make real money and
not be just reliant on grants.
So maybe talk about
that a little bit.
Yeah.
I think, yeah, I mean,
I do know that they
have come into Africa in the
fiction space, specifically.
I know a couple of filmmakers.
There's this Nigerian director
called Moolaadé, who's had--
actually, she has a
film that's coming out
of Netflix quite soon.
There's a few Kenyan
directors Toshi Tonga,
executive producer Fakii
Liwali who's Kenyan,
and the Nigerian filmmakers
and South African
filmmakers who have had either
originals or acquisitions done
by Netflix.
So it's quite exciting that
they're coming into this space.
And I'm sure they'll coming
to documentary quite soon.
Because it's true what you're
saying, grants are great,
but they're highly competitive.
So it's good to be
able to diversify
your sources of financing.
And I think we're very
excited about that, the fact
that they've come
to the continent.
And hopefully,
hopefully, HBO and Amazon
and all the other people
are going to follow.
Yeah.
I mean, there's, with the global
reckoning on race, there is a--
parachute filmmaking, as
you call it, isn't really--
no one tolerates that anymore.
You know, they can't get
away with that anymore.
And those people
who parachute in
to tell the stories
of Africa, those films
are not getting they're not--
they're not getting green-lit.
They're not getting seen.
And that's because of the
work that you guys have done.
Because people realize that
superior work is coming out
of--
from the filmmakers who
lived those experiences
You know, I do want to talk
a little bit about the change
in Kenya with the government
and the official change
and the way people
perceive nonfiction.
Because this year, The Letter,
the documentary The Letter,
was the Kenyan
submission to the Oscars.
I mean, how could that--
that must have been--
that was groundbreaking.
Oh, that was incredible.
Like, we were so happy for
the directing team, Maria
and Chris.
Yeah Because yeah, we
have filmmaking community
like in East Africa.
So we're always talking
about our stories
and sharing our experiences
with each other.
So we were so happy about that.
And there was a lot
of encouragement
from other filmmakers who
had gone through this Oscar
committee selection process
at a national level,
to be able to encourage
them on how to apply.
And the fact that they got
chosen was a validation of--
a validation in Kenya that
documentary is cinema.
I mean, I know that, but a
lot of people don't know that.
So I do know a lot of people who
are like, huh, a documentary.
And they did a theatrical
release after their selection.
And so many people went
to watch the documentary.
And so many people were
blown away by their access,
by their storytelling
I mean, Maia and Chris
have so many stories to tell
about their filming process.
And it's such a beautiful,
nuanced documentary.
And I'm so glad
that people actually
got to see it in theaters.
People are continuing to see it.
Yeah.
I just wish they'd gotten
support for the Awards, right?
But we're hoping that next
year, the Kenyan submission
will get some support
for the Awards from.
Yeah.
Incredible.
Well, before we run out of time,
I want to get to some questions
from student filmmakers.
So the first question
is, what does it
mean to "develop"
a documentary idea,
and what steps are
involved and when
do the idea is ready to pitch?
Wow.
OK.
I'll try and be brief.
There's a lot there.
OK.
I'll try and be as
succinct as possible.
I would say development is
testing your thesis statement.
You might think you
might have an idea
and say, oh, I want to do
something about like farmers
and how climate change actually
affects them in rural villages.
So that could just
be the general idea.
And then what you would
do is probably gather
a team, maybe a cameraman
and sound person.
Or you would go
yourself with, maybe,
a small camera, your
phone, and go and interview
different people to try and
maybe get a farmer to follow,
maybe interview some experts,
and then also do some research
as you're filming or even
before you go into the field
just to understand, is this does
this idea have any validity,
are there areas that we
could explore further.
And then I would just say it's
just continuing that process.
And I think when you feel
like you have a few hours,
I would say, 15 to
30 hours of filming,
you could review your footage
and try and edit, maybe,
something small that you think
summarizes the who, what,
where, why part of the story.
And yeah.
You would also accompany that
with a write-up, a proposal.
And there's lots of
resources online where
you can be able
to just understand
how to create these specific
things that I'm talking about
because I'm just talking
about it in brief.
There's lots of
online resources.
And Sundance Collab has
a lot of free master
classes on how to actually
develop documentaries.
And I would urge you
to go there and just
look at that in detail.
Yeah
Yeah.
I've done the Collab
master class myself.
Next question is what
is it like to show
your film at international
film festivals like Sundance?
And what does a producer
do at a festival?
OK.
Yes I will try and keep
this brief as well.
Yeah.
It was amazing to just be
at this A-list festival
that we never even
dreamed we could ever
have a film in competitions.
That was just incredible.
And we made sure we took the
time to live in the moment.
We even had an African-themed
party at Sundance
because there was a number of
African documentaries and films
that were there.
So we had a Kenyan
DJ, a Nigerian DJ.
So we were the best party
at Sundance last year.
I heard that .
I'm sorry I missed it.
We were the best party.
And we played music everywhere.
So people understood that there
were different kinds of music
and cultural nuances in Africa.
We're not-- we're not a country.
And then I would say, outside
of that, I think at a festival,
my work specifically,
was fundraising,
to ensure that we could take
the subject and the film team
to the festival.
So going back to our
partners and reaching out
to new partners to support us.
And then it was
organizing the premiere.
Because you have
to do a guest list.
You have to make sure all
materials are delivered,
and then working
with a publicity team
to make sure that you're
getting the right kind of press
for your project.
And also if you have a
sales agent at that point,
it's just making
sure distributors,
broadcasters are actually
watching your documentary.
Yeah.
And then I'd say, outside
of that, yeah, having fun.
Yeah.
Because your first
premiere only happens once.
Everyone-- everyone
talks about how--
you met everyone at Sundance.
I don't know how you did it.
But everybody would
come to me and be
like, I met Toni and Sam.
Everyone.
We were having so much fun.
Yeah.
You guys--
We were tired, but
we had so much fun.
Yeah, yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
Next question is
what types of stories
do you think we can
tell as refugees
living in camps in Kenya?
Wow.
I would say--
I mean, that's a great question.
I would say as a refugee
living in a camp in Kenya,
my. working assumption is that
it's other people telling you
stories I would say,
it's maybe looking
at what you find interesting
about your life, that maybe
doesn't fit into the narrative
that you think has been created
about your own experience.
Because I mean, I want to--
I'm sure, I'm sure
people fall in love.
I'm sure there's interesting
dynamic between you
and your siblings.
I'm not trying to be simplistic.
But I'm just saying,
like, just understanding
what it means from
your perspective,
to be living in that place
and in this point in time.
So I would just be like
look inwards a little bit
just in terms of what
you think is interesting
and what appeals to you
about your experience
or about your friends
living in the camp.
And you could just start
with a short story.
There's lots of short stories
that you-- short documentaries
you can find online.
I would urge you
to look at Topic.
It has amazing
short documentaries.
New York Times: Op-Docs has
amazing short documentaries.
If I think of other ideas,
I will read them up.
But if you start looking
for short documentaries,
that will take a
short amount of time.
I would say, just
start researching
and find things that
spark your interest.
Because I think it's
important that you,
as people who live
in the refugee camps,
ensure that you
tell a story that
shows the different dimensions
of what it means to be you,
that there isn't one story,
that you're not just victims,
you're not just
displaced people,
your people's hopes and
dreams, who are complicated
nuanced, and have the right
to share your own story.
Yeah.
Absolutely, absolutely.
And I think that's good advice
that sort of, watching shorts.
I have a series on
Topic, on shorts.
BIPOC filmmakers from
around the world.
And I show their short films.
And I think that just to watch--
just watch someone can
accomplish in storytelling,
seeing what can be accomplished
in a short amount of time,
whether it's 5 minutes or
15 minutes or 30 minutes,
it's just powerful,
powerful, powerful.
And you can do that
with little resources.
So it's just a great
way or place to begin.
OK.
Two more questions.
We're running out of time.
I'm going to-- so more women
are writing and directing
movies and series, do you think
we will see more Kenyan women
filmmakers soon?
OK.
So that's an
interesting question.
Actually, Kenya is an anomaly
because across the world,
the film industry tends
to be male-dominated.
But in Kenya, a lot of the
directors and producers
are women.
We have a long history of women
filmmakers being pioneers.
There's Anne
Mungai, [INAUDIBLE]..
There is Judy Kibenge
who founded DocuBox
who also directed fiction.
There's Njeri Karago who
was a Hollywood executive
and came back to
produce documentaries.
There's Wanuri
Kahiu, with Rafiki.
So I would just say
that we're quite
fortunate to be an anomaly.
Because there is some level of
gender parity in this country.
And I think it will only
get better and better.
Why do you think that is?
Why do you think so
many Kenyan women are
directing films and succeeding?
You know, oh, god,
I'm going to--
I'm going to get in
trouble for this.
But I think it's--
well, I think it's--
I mean, it's interesting
because when,
you know, when people were first
doing documentaries and film,
it tended to be NGO-funded.
And I guess, that to a certain--
I mean, the first people who
started directing and producing
those projects,
tended to be women.
So it was gender based issues.
So I think that that's where
it comes from a certain degree.
And outside of that, I
would just say it's--
my generation, in
my 30s, it's also
just because I saw women
like Njeri Karago produce.
And I knew it was possible.
I didn't have those
gender barriers
where it was just men
producing in my country.
So I think it just it was
just possible for women
to produce and
make me-- and men,
I think for some reason,
the men who were pioneers
in the industry,
tended to gravitate
towards like
cinematography, editing.
Because I guess, they
had toys to play with.
But I'm not really sure
what the reason is.
Those are just my oppinions.
Well, I think it's
something like the strong,
powerful African woman,
the backbone of every facet
of society, you know, from
carrying water - to...
Yeah.
That's that.
We're the organizers.
Yeah, yeah.
So it makes sense.
And same thing in the
documentary in the West.
I'd see now many
women are really
incredible force in the
documentary industry
in the West too.
So OK.
So we're running out of time.
Last question for you is
who are your role models
and what filmmakers
inspire you the most?
Oh, wow.
That is such a
difficult question.
Wow.
You should be-- we should,
how should filmmakers
be sort of looking out
for inspiration if they
want to watch the films,
you know, and be inspired.
Who do you turn to?
OK.
I would say-- I would
say, definitely,
I love Ousmane Sembéne.
I mean, he's a prolific
African storyteller.
And I think it was interesting
because at the time that he was
directing, a lot of
African countries
were achieving independence.
And they were
navigating what it meant
to be a post-colonial
state, and what it meant
to craft your own identity.
So a lot of his films speak
to that in one way or another.
And I find his
projects, his stories,
especially revisiting them now,
I find it very interesting.
Because I feel, at least,
specifically for Kenya, like,
we are reimagining what
it means to be Kenyan
and what it means to be a
country that's not really
forged its own identity
after decades of colonialism.
I think we're still grappling
with that as a country.
So that's what-- I mean, his
work really resonates with me.
And I'll just say because
he's a classical filmmaker.
He's fantastic.
And then there's this other
African filmmaker called,
Djibril Diop.
I can never say his
first name properly.
But he did this amazing fiction
film called Touki Bouki.
I would just urge
everyone to just watch it.
Djibril Diop, who's related to
Mati Diop, who did Atlantic.
I mean, his films were
very experimental.
And I just found it interesting.
I was like, a guy in the '70s
and '60s was experimenting,
I mean, with this new form.
That's so brave and fearless.
And yeah.
I think those are the
people I really look up to.
And I mean, internationally,
you know, you Roger,
as a filmmaker, I mean,
you're a great pioneer.
I would say Ava, with the work
she's doing, with a great crew.
I mean, there's just so
many inspiring filmmakers.
I mean, the list is quite long.
But those are the ones
that come to mind.
Yeah.
Well, I would say that you,
Toni, are an inspiration
not only being the
youngest producer invited
to the Academy, youngest
African woman producer invited
to the Academy, but as governor
of the doc branch, when
we looked around the
continent for someone
who could really speak to the
new movement on the continent
in nonfiction filmmaking, and
who is doing incredible work,
and just could represent
the community, you know,
we didn't have to look
any further than you.
So I thank you for
everything that you've
done for Kenya and East Africa
and the continent and all
the filmmakers that you inspire
and all that we're going
to hear from you in the future.
You have so much.
I mean, you're just bubbling
up with so much energy.
And the work that we are
going to receive from you
is going to be so incredible.
So thank you so much
for what you do.
And thank you for being
part of this conversation.
And yeah.
It's so great to talk to
you, so great to talk to you.
Same here.
Yeah.
I'm so excited.
Thank you.
It was amazing.
Great.
And there's more of us coming.
There's more of us coming.
It's not just me.
There is.
Get ready.
Well, I want to thank the
Academy Visiting Artists Series
and Toni for being here with us.
Toni, this was a pleasure.
And thank you so much.
Thank you so much, Roger.
It was really amazing
talking to you.